Why Russia is afraid of Finland.
Finland has just become the 31st country to join NATO
after almost a century of neutrality.
Finland joining NATO more than doubles
the common border between Russia and NATO.
So in case of war between these two,
Russia will have to stretch its defence line
all the way to Northern Europe.
Beside that,
Russia's second largest city,
Saint Petersburg,
will be under direct threat of NATO troops.
The entire Gulf of Finland will be under NATO control,
meaning that the Russian
Baltic Fleet will be almost completely neutralized.
And the link with Kaliningrad
is becoming extremely fragile.
Joining NATO used to be a red flag for Russia.
But today, seeing the actions in Ukraine,
more countries are more scared of being neutral
than Putin's warnings,
which will lead to other countries entering NATO.
What Russia really wants in Ukraine.
In the last centuries,
Russia really had a hard time
defending its western flank,
as it was proved in the Napoleonic Wars
and in the Second World War.
Stretching from the Netherlands in the west
all the way to Ural Mountains in the east.
The North European plane is the reason for Russia
inability to defend the invasions coming from Europe.
In order to defend itself,
Russia always wanted to control territory
as close as possible
to the narrowest point of this plane,
which is located in northern Germany.
During the Cold War,
Russia managed to reach this narrow point
by his proxies
from the Warsaw Pact.
And completely secured his western flank.
But when the Soviet Union collapsed,
it left in its place 15 new independent states.
Every former proxy state joined NATO,
together with the three Baltic states.
If Ukraine would join NATO,
Russia would not be able to stand any chance
against a NATO invasion across the entire border.
To prevent this,
Russia decided to act first
and to attack Crimea
and then the rest of Ukraine
in order to shift its defense line
as far as possible from Moscow.